welcome just spartan bowl in honor of
super bowl weekend 343 studios have
forged up a foosball inspired playlist
that will only be up until Sunday
februari second so if you still got that
copy of halo 4 round this is definitely
worth a quick pickup match so let's take
a look at what Spartan bowls packing
playing off the Ricochet game type two
teams Seahawk and Bronco themed
obviously on a virtual football field
make everyone visible but let's throw in
some transparent walls and oh baby now
we're talking and you're going to want
to use these walls to your advantage at
a Juke move here and there and take that
point down different loadouts correspond
to different positions play as a guard
and set up a drone for defensive place
or jump in as a Grenadier and pick out
players with a hologram as you dash for
the ball regardless once you get that
ball all you got are those one-hit
beatdowns so making a run for the end
zone isn't always the best strategy calm
down and show some patience grab the
ball hold back and form up with your
team the carrier will almost always go
down so someone needs to pick that ball
up for that final push and on the flip
if the other team is plowing through
your defensive line get that [ __ ] out of
their stupid pick that ball up and chuck
it downfield see what you will about
halo 4 multiplayer this match type is an
absolute blast beat downs and kills
fries are back with a twist and nothing
beats that rush you get as you're
bolting for the end zone touchdown or
goal I guess so come on dust off that
copy of halo 4 and give it a try because
remember spartan bowl is short-lived and
we'll be ending this Sunday so get it on